bonjour à vous gauthier rybinski
en parler ensemble alors il y à des
exercices communs assez fréquent entre
la russie et la chine des exercices un
militaire en août dernier on le sait au
moins dix mille soldats avaient été
déployés dans le cadre de ces exercices
mais pour autant livrer des armes à une
russie en guerre ce serait un nouveau
cap à franchir pour pékin oui un double
cap parce que vous savez que le
traditionnellement la chine
veut ou prétend respecter
scrupuleusement est strictement
l'intégralité territoriale deux pays
donc le des pays du monde de l'onu qui
sont reconnus par l'onu ça veut dire ne
pas se mêler des affaires intérieures
des autres pays et en échange bien sûr
personne ne doit être autorisé à se
mêler des affaires intérieures de la
chine c'est la raison pour laquelle les
ouïgours vivent un calvaire et que
personne ne réussit à sa 101 s'en
préoccuper véritablement donc ça c'est
la première chose justifier une attaque
de l'ukraine par la russie
ça veut dire qu'on change complètement
de perspectives pour la chine dans ce
domaine là la deuxième raison du
comportement de pékin c'est que au fond
dans cette rafle affrontements qu'on
nous présente qui est sans doute réel
entre les etats-unis et la chine pékin
n'est pas pressé de cet affrontement
n'est pas pressé de d'être confronté aux
états unis bien sûr il ya la puissance
commerciale mais on voit bien que quand
joe biden dit attention si vous
franchissez la ligne ou le rubicon le
fleuve pour soutenir les russes ça sera
méchant pour vous et comme vous le savez
dans l'immédiat la chine malgré son
poids militaire vous l'avez souligné
c'est aussi surtout un poids commercial
et le poids commercial ça veut dire
continuer le business et quand il ya une
guerre ça favorise pas le business donc
voilà pourquoi pékin et disons mi figue
mi raisin dans cette affaire parce que
elle c'est que d'un côté bien sûr les
difficultés de la russie vont les
difficultés commerciales par exemple ont
incité les russes à se tourner vers les
importations chinoises encore plus donc
ça ça fait des revenus pour la chine
qu'ils vont peut-être demandé et c'est
ce qu'on est en train d'évaluer des
armements à la chine mais qu'en même
temps ça peut entraîner la chine dans un
contexte quel ne veut pas assumer aussi
rapidement alors on le sait en temps
normal c'est plutôt l'inversé plus tôt
la russie qui fournit des armes à la
chine est ce qu'une demande de
fourniture d'équipements qui prendrait
finalement le sens inverse et sociaux se
serait pas dire au monde finalement que
moscou est en état de détresse alors si
vous voulez oui parce que moscou est en
état de détresse militaires ça on l'a vu
et surtout on le comprend par rapport à
ce qui avait été décidé en russie après
2008 2008 c'était la sphère géorgienne
de l'ossétie du sud la prési petite
guerre pardonnez moi le terme entre
guillemets mais qui avait révélé des
lacunes et des carences dans le
comportement dans le commandement et
même dans l'armement futile peu
sollicité à l'époque mais c'était quand
même la réalité et ont pensé que moscou
avait procédé à cette réforme or ce que
l'on vient de voir et que l'on voit tous
les jours avec nos envoyés spéciaux
c'est précisément la difficulté
militaire de moscou difficulté d'avoir à
fait à faire face à des armées
ukrainiennes qui est très en-deça au
niveau militaire mais qui a les moyens
de répliquer justement par des missiles
sol air ou sol sol et donc pour moscou
ça veut dire qu'il y a un problème
d'armement que beaucoup de ces chars ont
été détruits et qu'elle n'est pas
capable on sent que cette guerre allait
se jouer en un éclair qu'elle n'est pas
capable d'assurer la relève en termes de
matériel et c'est pour ça pique un
l'aiderait c'est une indication vous
avez raison sur l'état de l'armée russe
pas uniquement d'ailleurs il faut pas
s'en limiter à l'état du matériel russe
mais là c'est autre chose sur l'état du
moral aussi le soldat peut être révélée
l'inquiétude de vladimir poutine merci
beaucoup